[Music]
it's Danny Daniels and her husband this
time world famous star at this point
awardwinning I'm the biggest of the
industry exactly anytime you date a guy
you're like please don't have a terrible
C working with Danny I was like dude you
have a huge dick he's like a Subway
sandwich if it's a big dick I like to
warm up before I like to get my w
stretching before the marage yeah I was
walking through the airport and my [__]
was going like this cuz he hading blown
it out for the last 2 hours guys will
send me their tiny micro and they want
me to roast them like that's the best
day ever is that hard okay why didn't
you send me a photo when you get fully
hard this the financial domination those
are my other
favorites I love a man's wallet Vic is
always a person that I can go to and if
I was like I want to get gang banged
like like 30 dudes he's something that I
can come to and not be ashamed afraid
let's just say that you did feel like
that one day Vick how would you deal
with that oh yeah what would you
do a big thank you to Danny Daniel shop
who are sponsoring today's podcast you
can get a bit of everything on there if
you're up for being on the naughty list
this Christmas this makes all of your
other toy shops and you know naughty
Shops look very boring as you can see
the lingerie you know if you're fancying
a little bit of a night go Vibe or if
you just want to be a sexy zebra we
can't we can't show that that's that's
mental now that yeah yeah Fant that is
fantastic isn't it the model doesn't
come with it did check this is a lovely
little two-piece Danny is wearing here
just with a real strict messaging just
in case you weren't sure I really feel
like I shouldn't be AOW to show this but
I mean it's not really anything there's
nothing wrong with this is it it's just
someone with a massive o-ring in our
mouth wow whips puddles and ticklers if
you're into a bit of the old bondage
we've all tried it haven't we this one
could be the perfect Christmas gift for
any of the women in your life probably
not your grandmother or your mother the
F machine pro now it's this sort of
action and it and it never gets tired
really putting men out of business I
know some of you will be familiar with
this sort of thing works like a charm
well it's a wand do you know what I mean
cast the spell come all over they've
also got the remote control one so that
you can like you know take your misses
out for dinner or whatever and you'll be
rushing her back into the taxi quickly
because it's all going off benwa balls I
don't actually know what these are I'm
assuming he just shove them up then oh
wow some of this I just can't show you
yeah it's a bit too naughty so I'm going
to let you L click the link in the
description below and go and check out
Danny Daniels website now it is
fantastic you can get something for
everyone have a Merry Christmas fill
your boots get as dirty as you want just
be safe enjoy the podcast use my link
click the link thanks cheers the link
they're definitely fine I've tested them
welcome back to the true JY podcast I'm
joined by two lovely people today with
familiar faces we've had them on before
it's Danny Daniels and her husband this
time uh Vic Chapa thanks for joining us
guys you I appreciate it if anyone
didn't see the last podcast I did
amazingly well with Danny uh world
famous porn star at this point award
winning you actually won performer of
the year I was just looking into the
history you know you've done well when
you get like the top girl of the
industry yeah I'm the biggest [__] of
the industry exactly cuz that's a do you
still have that trophy oh yeah I have
quite a few I think I'm up to like over
20 at this point yeah like 2 I have to
like hide them when the in-laws come
over but you know
yeah I don't want to know I was that
good um we throw a sheet over the trophy
like and yeah it was funny cuz you got
and you gave your acceptance speech and
I was like what are po acceptance speech
awards like and you were like I didn't
think I was going to win this cuz I
don't give up the booty hole was the
worst it was the worst like I never I I
try to not ever drink when I'm doing
events okay and I was like there's no
way I'm going to win cuz I don't give up
the butt so I was like you know what I'm
going to have a whiskey like whatever
and then I win I was like uhoh
that's wild yeah I think I went on stage
and I was just like yeah was the ego was
your ego a little bit like cuz you're
competing against a lot of pretty women
it's a big thing isn't it yeah yeah and
like I said like I wasn't expecting it
when I did so I was yeah it it took me a
while like it probably didn't hit me
until like 5 10 minutes later I was like
oh oh and like it showed I was like oh
okay well guess I'm really good at
sucking dick this is cool I mean he can
very there's a nod there um and yeah for
those who don't know uh you've done a
lot of different types of porn there was
Kink there was all sorts of things you
were talking on your videos about crying
after orgasms onet I was like wow this
is wild I know yeah and they would have
to like check in with me obviously like
for legality reasons they'd be like you
know especially with Kink they would
have to like go in and be like okay you
were crying are you okay you know did
you did you are you where you had the
safe for I was like yeah I was fine I
was just like living my best life
having like crying orgasms like any
woman would
enjoy it's that would terrify me if a if
a woman after sex starts crying I'm like
oh [__] get reported what about during
sex what about during sex you're like
Terri
immediately I mean sorry can we get you
a cup of tea is everything all right uh
have you ever done that together is that
something that's happened oh yeah
absolutely yeah yeah so you're just like
a crier she's a happy crier I know it
sounds really horri when you say it out
loud but yeah like I am I'm very like
I'll probably cry like I'm tearing up
now like when I laugh or if I'm having a
good time I'm like a like a she's
actually happy cry and not a sad cry
funny yeah that's M even if I see like
an emotional commercial I'm just like
that's so sweet like yeah and like the
well the the list went on and you pretty
much like did a whole bunch of stuff
before you met Vic specifically and I
think one of the reasons I wanted to
have Vic on this time is a to understand
the dynamic of the but also now more
than ever in society people are talking
about men who are with promiscuous women
as they say like in in a certain kind of
way and I just kind of want to explore
this with you guys um because you from
what I remember you didn't meet in a oh
he was a porn guy kind of way you met in
a normal way is that right we met we met
at a baby shower yeah wow was so nice so
hot so nice like the most innocent thing
you could ever do I mean it was a porn
star's baby shower but it was a baby
shower okay well it's a little bit weird
now but so so was it like a love a first
sight thing or just uh best friends at
first yeah best friends yeah we I mean
there was I think there was something
there between the two of us but neither
one of us wanted to dive off that diving
board right away until it just kind of
kind kind of just happened how did you
know the pwn star I didn't oh I didn't I
actually the person that I was with
somebody who I was representing at the
time and I I knew who she was because of
the person that I was with at the time
but I didn't really know her or the I
mean I had kind of aged out of porn at
that point you know going through that
yeah right yeah you kind of age out of
it at some point you know it's like H
okay you know appar there's a statistic
about that like you hit 40 yep and I'm
in like my mid-30s and I'm like I I
barely watch it what's going on this has
been like a something I've done every
day like 20 years and now I'm like I
haven't I can't remember the last time I
watch it it's weird it's it's it's
usually like between 4 and 45 it drops
off like dramatically and that's like a
norm why do you got do you think there's
a reason for that or I maybe it's like a
combination of things maybe um you've
seen it all maybe you've gotten to page
256 you're like you know or maybe uh you
know girls getting in at 18 21 whatever
it is maybe it seems too young uh um
there's like a bunch of different life
kind of happens at that point you're in
your 40s your career is going you're
probably married hopefully good
hopefully you're getting it good and
yeah yeah you're getting it on top you
you shouldn't need as much and then when
you hit like 45 if you've had kids like
I did where they were young when you
were young you're like okay these are
the same age as my kid okay now yeah I'm
done now I'm done I think also too it's
like you as couples a lot I feel like
have like I've noticed like as people
get older fans get older they start to
watch it as a couple more yeah so that's
pretty cool I think it's really
cool and like coup's experimenting is
become is becoming more and more normal
obviously a guy I was hanging out with
the other day told me like he was
freaking out though he was like I've
just found out a couple I know they're
swingers and was really like traumatized
by I couldn't be doing that like and at
the same time that's never occurred to
me but I'm assuming it's pretty normal
for you guys to know people who do that
is that oh yeah like yeah we I mean wide
breath from utterly vanilla to overthe
toop and the people who are over top
tend not to be the adult film stars that
we know it's it's like the average
person you know five doors down in
Florida that makes perfect sense cuz he
said they were a couple who hadn't
experimented a lot got together young
and then when they hit like I don't know
mid 30s are like we have we've missed
out on a lot yeah and then they felt
like they wanted to do it as a team I
love that I actually I love like the
open communication and talking about and
being able to experiment together like I
think that's something that is just so
so beautiful in its own way and knowing
each other's limits and just like I
don't know I just I feel like that's
something that's more popular now than
maybe you know 10 20 years ago and the
fact whereas maybe before Oh I want to
do this and it would maybe lead to like
cheating or leaving or you know divorce
where now it's like you know I've never
had a three-way well I've never been
with a woman you want to go find
somebody at the bar like it is tricky as
a man as well of like cuz
guys I think women don't understand how
sex is a a chemical thing for us B like
I don't mean it trigger got some women
out there but like women have chemical
things happen them every month that men
have to sort of deal with sometimes and
and women don't understand like where're
going through some chemical stuff as
well and our brain when we're out on the
street we see a beautiful woman it's
it's not a choice to have that thought
it really is preprogrammed I mean it's
why we're all here women do that too
yeah I'm sure I'm sure I just feel like
men are less uh we're filling up every
day sort of thing we're we're also less
subtle about it like women are smart
enough to keep it quiet and we'll be
like
damn they beeping their own um so you
you guys are at this little innocent
well quite innocent party and you get
talking were you how quickly before you
spoke about the fact that you in the
industry oh no I knew I knew she was in
so yeah I had I had known when we met
that she was in the industry um almost
everybody in the room except me was in
the industry so yeah so um we actually
became best friends for about a year and
a half before we started dating yeah why
do you think you'd had that perod of
best friends rather than going straight
to relationship like a lot of people do
um I was in a relationship at the time
yeah so was I and I don't what no no it
wasn't it really wasn't it does it
sounds like it was but it wasn't I I'm a
publicist I I do pr for a living and I
did a lot of art PR and my wife is a
world-renowned artist actually I mean
Beyond just the adult film star she's
like so she was showing me her artwork
and I'm like Jesus this is awesome I
like let me help you out with some that
that's we kind of became friends over
that and then I had a bad breakup and
she had a worse breakup and then we
bonded over the fact that we literally
hate humans was like be
quite and then it it became it was
actually almost a good thing it became a
situation where we kind of realized we
had this attraction to each other we're
like all right here's all the crap yeah
you know here it is here's all the
problems I'm not young anymore this is
what it is and she went well yeah well
here's all my crap and we're like hey
our crap matches
yeah it's like this is what I want in a
partner this is what I want in bed this
is what I'm into this is like my like
you know what I want for the future and
we literally like sat together and like
had like almost like a business
transaction but like in the best way
you're checking off that checks off a
box that checks off a box I think it
because we were friends first for so
long that like when it was so organic
when it even happened and I literally
looked at him and I was like I should
just date you and he's like okay that's
how we started dating that's that's like
really healthy though isn't it to get
everything out in the early that's when
people who are knowing each other sorry
knowing themselves and therefore able to
just put it all out there and a lot of
people they waste time when you're
younger especially pretending to be the
version of you that is yes I said that
to him I was like everyone has [__]
for the first 6 months and then and then
the real person and then yeah they like
they like you wear this like fake facade
like even if you don't even know you're
doing it but for us M Mr Hyde pops out 6
months later like where the hell is this
guy and that's why like in my own life
I'm few months later you're like who the
[__] am I dating here but it's just the
real them coming out yeah like oh oh so
you oh yeah you covered the bag of [__]
for a while it's like oh awesome thanks
I appreciate that but but then when
you're having these moments where you're
both in relationships and talking do you
think deep down you there was more there
but you were just like kind of putting
it on pause I don't you know what yeah
maybe um but we were I mean neither one
of us were doing anything I mean most of
our conversation were about her artwork
literally at that point and um and it
was I mean it was only like 3 or four
months before I had a break up and then
it was like a month later and then we
were friends for about a year and um she
came to New York uh specifically to
promote her artwork and I was getting
her meetings and it just you know it was
like at one point and we we always talk
about this one point in time we both got
a drink and we reached and kind of like
you know like literally out of a movie
like our hands touched and we looked at
each other and it was kind of like uh oh
like literally was like uh oh s like the
biggest fear right like you don't want
to date your friend because then if it
goes south friend yeah it's like so but
that's quite romantic it really was cute
and gushy and gross you what you expect
from I like it yeah and in a week we're
married six years yeah literally one
week from today yeah and in terms of the
toxic breakups that you both went
through that you bonded over um if you
don't mind me asking not that is how
toxic are we talking like what was those
experiences like for you oh God awful
like like got awful
yeah and I and I know I sent you my book
like in the front part of it you like I
started listing off just everything that
I put up with and you know I I mean it's
it's kind of like comfort's like a bean
bag chair it seems like it's really
comfortable and then you got to get up
and you're like oh this sucks and and
that's what happens is like you just
accept a little bit more [__] a little
bit more [__] a little bit more [__] and
now all of a sudden you're 6 months in
and you're like what the hell am I doing
and it's like it literally hits nothing
there's nothing about this relationship
I like I think both of our breakups were
so bad that it put us in a mental state
where we were like [__] it this is what
I want like I don't care if I sound
shallow like I don't care like I want
this this and this like I was I think we
were both in that because I think if one
of us was and one of us wasn't it
wouldn't have worked but because we both
were just so bitter and it was like look
I want and C just don't give me [__] can
you be ab and c and if not it's cool
like that's what I want in a
relationship and so isn't it weird how
sometimes you need to have like the
worst possible experience in order to
develop a zero tolerance policy yes
absolutely cuz I definitely have been
there where after that one I'm like
ain't no way you're bringing me down no
I'm not allowing anyone to do that again
yeah you're like I just went through all
of that uhuh I'm not even getting
halfway through that [__] again
there also becomes a point in time and
we did and we were friends and we had I
mean she was living in California I was
in New York so it wasn't like we were
seeing each other starting a
relationship there a point in time where
you have to get comfortable with
yourself and you have to like look be
able to look in the mirror and go you
know what I have no problem being alone
until the right person comes if the
right person comes it might not but if
the right person because then you're
comfortable in your own skin and you're
not just looking for that relationship
cuz I need something that fulfills me
now I'm fulfilling myself and also if
you're alone if you're alone I feel like
you've got hope at least like when
you're stuck in that [__] relationship
you got nothing yeah when you're like
settling for being that you're like oh
God but I guess I can't do any better
you're like if you're better off alone
just be alone like at that point like my
hand is great exactly exactly
like wow um and then obviously you're
still in the porn industry at that point
yeah and how long after you and Vic
became an item did you calm that down
because you're still in porn but you
stopped working with other male
performers yeah it's it was pretty quick
but it didn't have anything to do with
Vic it was like it was honestly like
this like perfect like [__] storm of
life that I was going through at the
time and I was wanting to move to New
York and shoot my own content and focus
on my own Brands so it honestly like
just it was pretty quick on but not it
wasn't like oh I'm so in love with this
guy I'm not going to take any other dick
it was just kind of like oh I'm I just
happen to be in this place where I've
[__] everyone I've wanted to [__] and
like I'm ready to like move on and move
to the next ch and then he it was it's
so funny how life works like that like
and then it was like oh I'm kind of
ready to like you know do my own thing
and move to New York and start my own
businesses and then he just like popped
up like something I hadn't even thought
of and then yeah it wasn't I there was
no we never had a conversation of okay
you need to step out she was stepping
out we happened it was like ancillary it
had literally nothing to do with each
other they were two different directions
she she had told me months before that
she was like you know I really kind of
want to phase out of the industry
there's really nothing much more that I
can do with it um and I want to move on
with my life and we never really it was
never a situation where it was like okay
you're going to stop now or she was
looking at me going I'm going to stop
now it just happened yeah I think a lot
of fans think that too and like what I
want to point out is like a lot of fans
like when because obviously when you
first date someone you're not putting
them on the internet right and so I
think when I started posting him it
happened to be along the same time that
I stopped performing with other
performers so people were like oh you
got with Vic and you stopped taking
other di like no it just happened to
work out that way did they give you
grief for that the fans cuz you have
dedicated fans I did I got a little bit
at first but in in a way it kind of
weeded out um fans that just wanted to
see me take as much like [__] and dick
as possible which is great and I had
that chapter in my life um but it kind
of brought in new fans like I have a
huge amount of couples that watch my
porn um fans that just love to watch me
be me like cuz cuz now it's like I I'm
[__] at home home I'm on my couch
it's like it's like real life you know
yeah people love that stuff yeah and so
it's kind of like it kind of just like
swung the pendulum in like a different
way but didn't you say that you have
like a a real cult following in India or
something I've seen you the weekend
getting pictures with fans there a lot
of Indian dudes yeah so it was funny I
did I actually did um I had my products
in a a shop Vibes pleasure Boutique and
um they're outside this out of London
outside of London excuse me and
I had fans Drive the some fans they like
4 hours another set of fans said six
hours each way up near the Scottish
border they were coming down to Alford
or whatever we I mean we were we were we
were in the South and they were coming
down they're like oh we just wanted and
they were I mean they were all they
always nice in seven years that we've
been together I can tell you we've had
only one interaction with a fan that was
annoying and it wasn't even like
obnoxious it was just annoying can you
explain that the guy was like half drunk
and like oh what's it like to [__] a
porn star and I'm like well something
you'll never know you know like but that
every other time they've been really
respectful hey do you mind and they
always ask me do you mind oh never mind
you know we're really happy for the fans
but never he's my giveaway it's annoying
his big old bald headed in a bar and
people see him they look they go could
that be and then they look and go oh
yeah like he's quite memorable GE like
yeah but but like driving 6 hours to see
you right like I'm a YouTuber I keep my
clothes on but even that would freak me
out a little bit it was it it was I
didn't know I was speechless I was just
like 6 hours each way yeah I was like
yeah they were I've done that drive it's
a it's a long drive yeah it's like it
was really it was honestly really
flattering if anything but I was just
kind of like I don't want to I wouldn't
drive 6 hours for anything do you know
do you know what my bring go to if
you'll drive 6 hours for that what what
else would you do yeah
where where how far is this what would
you do for the kondik bar just trying to
figure this out here you scary but so
how do you watched Danny I'm going to
call you
Danny I know that's your daughter's
ironic whole another a whole another
story talk about that later um so had
you watched Danny's uh porn videos no
never why I have it live even now even
now especially now whye now because I
have it live why do I need to watch it
on video so um I think that would really
surpris people though like when I like I
think I I heard you say that in a
interview I remember thinking wow cuz
like if if I was friends with a porn
star and then if I'm dating a porn star
like just let's just put this scenario
together it's that like curiosity more
than anything it's not even like it's
not even necessarily a dirty thought
like I got to see what's been going what
scenes that she like to do I mean don't
get me wrong I I have lovely people who
send me photos on a regular basis and
I'm and I always laugh it's like do you
think I didn't know this exist
oh dud DM yeah D DM they're like oh look
at your wife and I'm like yeah okay
great congratulations you found the
photo that's you know on Twitter you I'm
thrilled for you but I I I find them in
this very weird position because we do
have a lot of friends in the industry
and they've become very close friends
and some of them are they're like family
so most guys would love to see their
wife's hot friends naked I can't not see
it and it's hard horrifying it's like
yeah it's like you know aesthetically
beautiful and emotionally crippling at
the same
time you're a really interesting dud I
say this respectfully like you're you're
quite a lovely guy but
equally uh different right cuz I just
can't imagine anyone I know being able
to take that approach just the the the
Curiosity but also then the other things
and you obviously don't think like most
men because I think most men a couldn't
be with a pawn star yeah but also they
couldn't even date upon star without
wanting to say
everything I remember this brings me
back I don't know why I'm talking about
this but a mate of mine had some old
videos of him with his previous girl on
his like computer or whatever they're
like home movie sit yeah a whole bunch
of them like 30 and his new girl who was
like he was having a kid with and all
that found it oh and and I said to him
like what did she do like did she take
your approach just you know I don't need
to say this this was before me no she
watched every single second because she
had to know I'm going to [__] him better
and that's what women are so like I
think that's a woman thing to be fair
but you must have some quite a bit of
mental strength just block that out and
just be like you know what it's not even
that I block it out I just don't care I
literally don't care I don't know right
I mean I wish I could tell you that I
had a reason I just don't care it's like
okay and people I I mean I've heard this
a bunch of times and I'm like look
Kieran Lee who was on your podcast
right had his dick inured for a million
dollars she had him she chose me I'm
fine I'm fine I like I'm fine I mean I
got it's I've just realized I've
actually seen your dick
before I followed I followed D on I'm
like there's my mate's dick is weird I
mean that that now that's a little on
the out side there's nothing wrong with
it it's perfectly fine but you're right
that's the key is you were like it's
weird I'm like yes cuz like it's like
all my my close friends in the industry
that come and stay at our house and
stuff it's a different Dynamic I think
people think that like off camera we're
all just like laying around in launder
having pillow fights and it's not it's
just like it's a job like anything else
so for him it's like you know seeing
like Shere DeVille naked who's like one
of my best friends and she's like I mean
sh's like a sister to
me yeah she's and and like I can't like
open up Twitter with I'm like cuz like
usually the thing I love about Vic is
that he doesn't care and I think people
assume that if you're in porn you can't
date what we call civilians because they
are jealous they'll ask you to quit the
industry they or they'll just like [__]
you for the story and that's the common
is that the norm the norm yeah like I'm
not sure you know oh it's either going
to be somebody that wants to [__] me for
the story that thinks they can handle it
and then can't that hears it from their
friends like oh you know your wife's a
porn star your girlfriend's a porn star
it's like and then they can't they think
they can mentally take it and they can't
so we need start to date so once I when
I was with Vic I was like oh he actually
doesn't give a [__] like it's so freeing
to not have to be worried or stressed or
constantly just like oh my God is you
know if Johnny SS comes up comes up to
us at a convention is he going to be
like kind of you know straightened up
you know but it's like not like that at
all like kieran's a perfect example
we've had drinks together and stuff and
laughed our asses off so it's and I mean
are comfortable in your in your
masculinity yeah cuz I've dated porn
stars I [__] porn stars I've dated
civilians like I I chose him like he's
the person I want to be with like I've
obviously [__] enough to know what I
want in bed and so it's like and you
obviously your age could have helped
with this because you're at a point
where you're a bit wiser you're not in
as you're not in that early years
masculine where you have to prove
yourself to everyone you've proven what
you need to prove but you've now also
got involved as I've said how did that
feel the first time you're like this my
dick's going to be on the internet like
how was that you want to laugh I didn't
care I didn't the one that was like she
was all she was all worried about it and
I'm like look this is this is what you
do I you know this is what we're going
to be then let's just do it and move on
I I'm bizarrely and I don't know why I
never grew up jealous in my life I have
a I have two brothers who are younger
than me and no one can ever tell you
that my especially my middle brother cuz
we're four years apart we never had a
fight ever there is not one member of
our family cuz I didn't care like he
would win trophies I would be proud of
him like he became a doctor I was proud
of him I didn't I never got that I've
never had that jealous feeling over
anything even business partners would
tell me like if if they went into the
refrigerator and ate ate something I
wanted I'd be like oh good did you like
it I just I'm not that person I don't
know why I CU when I've reached out to
you and just said cuz you're a
businessman I'm asking you things you're
very generous very given sure you could
verify that he's very
giv um but no like you said you were
worried about him yeah I was the one
that was stressed out about it like it
actually took quite a while to be like
okay like I would be like are you sure I
was like he's like let's just shoot like
who cares let's just shoot content just
use my dick like it's fine and I was
like and I took I was the one yeah just
he's like I mean you think about it now
it's like guaranteed sex twice a week
like oh yeah no honey I'm here for you I
got you it's no problem supp HB I'll be
here you yeah but I was the one that it
took me like quite a few weeks to be
like okay like is this something that
you know I I I felt responsible you know
because this wasn't like he him being
like oh he wouldn't have done this
without you yeah and I didn't want to
like I wanted to make sure that it was
something that you were okay with
because I've talked about this before
but like porn is a life sentence like
it's not something that you do once and
then it's just like the internet is
always forever so I really wanted to
make sure but as you can see he care and
you marry in you know I mean look I I
and I and I get it and I like even Age
and what you got to know what you're
getting into you got to know I mean I'm
I'm I'm marrying not just an adult film
star a person who's been in the top 25
for a decade I mean we don't go any that
she isn't noticed we got stopped at the
Vatican for a photo and that's a true
story I mean like we got stopped at we
can't go anywhere without her being
noticed so I know what I'm signing
up you have kids though so so was was
there a worry that you were like like
from your side like oh my God like are
they ads they're adults yeah they're
adult I don't have kids have adults yeah
but even even then um was that a
conversation that you had or did you
just do it that no that was a
conversation her and I had about it like
you know your kids have to be okay with
it my kids didn't care I mean honestly
you described that conversation I'm
going to need to know so it bizarrely it
was don't give too much of cuz I'm very
proud I'm like I'm very protective like
protective so like so there's a running
joke story that when she came to New
York the first time uh my both my kids
were there I have a son and a daughter
both my kids were there and they were
looking at the two of us and privately
they had a bet when we were going to
start dating they just saw it they knew
they just knew and my daughter won and
she'll appreciate that when she watches
this podcast that she won the B my son
still owes her the money so she'll even
appreciate that too but yeah but they
they and like her and my daughter are
very close and my my son and I are very
close and it just you know it it they
were smart enough to realize dad's happy
and happy dad makes for for a good dad
so they're so liberal right so L yeah
they would they would chill about it and
I mean you know everybody in the
beginning was what were you know you
shortest is going to and then everyone
that I came across on your side of our
relationship they all said like we just
we just love seeing Vic happy like we
don't care like no one I mean it was
very few people like very few people
with in anything would was were no judgy
comments no I mean like we had we had
our share of them but they were from the
outside not from like good close friends
it's the same people that would judge me
for doing porn anyway you know so I'm
like okay moving on you know and I mean
I was shock and awe like the first 6
months of the relationship um people
were looking at it going uh and then
Testament to my wife she made everybody
comfortable everybody's like oh my God
she's awesome she's great look at how
happy Vic is it's not you know it's not
what we it's not what we were expecting
it to be which is always the answer we
get with this as you move forward your
energy from following you guys for years
now is it is very close it isn't like
you know I guess people if they look
from the outside in they'd look at your
relationship and think oh he's a sugar
daddy or something that was big in the
beginning yeah a lot of people people
thought I left the industry to be with
the sugar daddy and I was like yeah I
could see I just like old guys like just
let me live my old guy life like I'm I'm
best I can also understand the fact that
like you know if you were to say I'm
[__] a porn star my girlfriend's a
porn star everyone is instantly going to
think the same thing oh that'll be over
in a month like you know oh you know
it's just like going to be like a fun
little thing that like you know so I
think once we got together for an
extended period of time and especially
now that we've been married for almost 6
years people are like oh yeah like yeah
you're not Anna Nicole Smith yeah yeah I
mean I people for those who don't
remember that was a really famous woman
who went up with a 90-year-old guy very
different yeah I think they think they
were together like six months and he
died just with him for his ARP card she
wanted the free cooler from a ARP but as
it happened when I was doing my research
apparently when you met you were
involved in this Charlie Sheen thing
yeah that was that was that was kind of
how we met the person that I was
representing was one of Charlie's exes
and the whole [__] hit the fan kind of
okay so so can we talk a little bit
about that cuz that's quite a
fascinating story in the industry right
so Charlie Charlie was very and Ricky ja
joked about this like if that was a
Monday then what was his New Year's Eve
like he was like hanging out with porn
stars and all the drugs and then
obviously HIV hits was that right yeah
he was HIV positive yeah he I guess he
was he was HIV positive for a while and
had hit it for a while and I was
representing somebody who at the time um
she he had hid it from and they were
together and they had gotten engaged I
mean this whole this whole relationship
is because of Charlie wow wow you only
successful
relationship maybe you know Charlie
Charlie and I are about almost like
almost a year apart he's like a year it
was a really big problem in the industry
because you know when you have men and
women going out and you know like like
when we got together like I made him get
tested before we [__] and a lot of
people don't do that and a lot of people
go out and they bring in like diseases
into the industry and then we have all
these like breakouts and then the
industry has to shut down so he was like
a massive problem but it's like what was
it like for those women who were
infected by
him I don't know a lot of them very
closely so I can't speak on their behalf
and I'm not sure that there's ever been
really a case of somebody who's been
infected by him I think I I really don't
know that for a fact um but it was
something that was kind of like hush and
hidden and it was it was a little I mean
this whole thing odd because when you're
[__] you know 5 to 15 people a week
and you hear about this and you're like
you hold your breath you're like as I've
always been very responsible in the
industry I've always gotten tested I've
always made the people that I was
[__] on the side get tested so to be
you know to hear something oh there's
going to be that that whole Scandal
happened I was like here we go like hope
my test doesn't come up I'm hope I don't
have to kill somebody and you know it's
it's bizarre because I know my age My
Generation getting tested was not a big
thing cuz I lived through wasn't HIV it
was AIDS you got it you died period that
was it you know I was in school when
that was like really scary so getting
tested was something you either did or
you got you know you were you were taken
your life in your had so when she asked
me to get tested I was like yeah no
problem and she was like really I'm like
yeah it's like I grew up with that I
grew up with that yeah and I do know
that and I've had this conversation with
kids and and friends you're like oh I
don't want to get tested I'm like are
you out of your mind yeah I mean get
tested you out of I don't want to know
you don't want to know yeah oh I don't
have any symptoms what like that's
that's insane get tested be safe I mean
that's just that's key yeah and just
knowing your status and like especially
if you're at you know you have partner
Partners like why not know and now a
word from our sponsors because the true
Jordy YouTube channel would not be able
to make as many great podcasts each
month as we do if it wasn't for our
great friends at manscaped and with
Christmas coming up there is no better
gift a man can receive than the kit from
manscaped and thanks to Tescos it's even
easier because they are stocking
manscaped across their stores in the UK
so all you last minute Shoppers I've got
you covered you can pick up the lawn Mo
4.0 which is one of their bestselling
products it's an electric body trimmer
that's waterproof cordless and designed
specifically for the most sensitive
areas of the body it's a fourth
generation trimmer with Advanced ceramic
blades and skin safe technology which
helps reduce Nicks and cuts and
seriously this product is fantastic and
Tesco also has the essentials 3.0 kit
that includes the lawnmower 3.0 and
includes a bottle of crop preserver
which is the anti-chafing bow deodorant
so what you're waiting for get to your
nearest test scores and make sure that
your balls are shining like Christmas
bubles you get it cuz of the enjoy it
enjoy it but enjoy the podcast as well
and in terms of marriage like marriage
is traditional and obviously you don't
come from a traditional working
background and you'd already been and
had a family so why did you guys think
marriage fit you w that's a really good
question um I you know it's funny I I
think when we first got together we
weren't sure we were going to get
married we were just going to and then
it just seemed right it just seemed
correct you know was like one of those
things where it's like we really wanted
to do this and it's not like the piece
of paper means anything but the ceremony
does and having your family there mean
something and having our friends and the
people that we care about meant
something the piece of paper is just
piece of paper birth doesn't really yeah
it wasn't even like a second thought of
if I should marry this person it was
just like well like even when we got
together I'm like this is the person I'm
going to spend the rest of my life with
like it was like an instantaneous like I
just like knew and and you didn't have
to get married though like a lot you so
it was it that ceremony and the vows and
and wanting to commit to each other so
that you have that feeling of security
there yeah I I I don't even know if
there was a feeling of security it's
more like a feeling of love that we
wanted to share with our friends and
family members and have everybody there
and have her family there my family
there and it wound up being it was I
mean it was a beautiful weekend and it
meant more like I said the piece paper
is just piece of paper yeah like even if
it wasn't like binding us together I
still would have done it just like a
celebratory of like our love not to get
all mushy no I mean it no cuz cuz that
when I was contemplating your Dynamic I
was like you know you don't need
marriage you know but you obviously felt
the need for it in in a in a sense and
it's especially with you Donnie because
you're just you you danced your own tune
and i' I found that from meeting you you
like you do everything your own way and
I just wondered what it was about it do
you know I mean that that makes sense
and in your head when you took those
vows were you like and it's definitely
over for me shooting with other men in
in that moment like maybe not in that
very moment but like around that time no
it's I think people associate marriage
with like monogamy and even though we
are monogamous and that's just something
that works for us like Vic is always a
person that I can go to and if like like
down the road I was like I don't know I
want to get gangbanged like like 30
dudes like I think he's something that I
can come to and not be ashamed afraid
like we can always have an open and
honest conversation and getting together
and getting engaged getting married like
that didn't even it didn't even cross my
mind that anything in the relationship
would change let let's just say that you
did feel like that one day Vick how
would you do with oh yeah what would you
do it would definitely be a conversation
that would have to there is you know
it's like we've had this conversation a
bunch of times going into it like did
you want to go back to the industry and
most of the time it ends like this yeah
I know what it's like to bang other
people yeah I it's never going to be the
same as being with you why do I want to
Ru what we have because it's like the
plate you throw it on the ground you
break it you can't put it back together
you can glue it back together but it
still got cracked yeah so that's so
that's by just it's like if you have if
you're in a monogamous relationship and
you want to be monogamous the moment you
break that you can't get that back it's
it's not coming back so we've had this
conversation it's like why do I want to
do this just for the sake of doing this
cuz that's all it is you know you I mean
look we're guys we've been around the
we've been around the block a few times
you've had those times where you've
banged somebody and afterwards you went
what did I do that for you know and
women have the same thing you're like
what did I do that and you can't get
back what you've lost by doing that so
same thing with us it's like we've had
this conversation many times and she's
even said she goes and it was like even
if it's like oh go back and do girl girl
it's like yeah it's the same thing I'm
by I [__] so much and I love I love
women I'm bisexual like but I've just
[__] so much [__] that I'm like I
know what pussy's like I've had plenty
of it that's you know I loved it but
it's just the reason I'm asking you
specifically this cuz I know people
watching will will I'm interested in
where the line is with you because
you've obviously you've been perfectly
fine with their previous um life in in
porn when you were active in that way
and you've not even felt the need to
watch them but it feels like you the
Line is now moving forward okay we're in
this together now and that you do want
that monogamy moving forward then at
this point yeah I we I think we both
have had this discussion and it's not
even it's not even that it would bother
me if she went back in the industry it
was just something like as we keep going
further and further in there's just
something incredibly loving and sweet
about it and it's I I personally can't
even imagine finding somebody else
at this point it's like I look at them
and I go yeah that's a really attractive
woman but I'm not ruining this for what
might I'm the one that's like you want a
[__] her yeah right she'll be like you
want a [__] her and I and and and I'll
literally go great I like so I'll get
into this you'll have sex with a woman
it'll be like screwing a wet mop and
I'll be like okay now I've ruined this
this beautiful thing that we had for a
horrible sexual experience wonderful
that just make hor be horrible I think
if it is it would be it's never going to
have the same emotional connection
that's just never going to be there so
so it it's it's very interesting that
that is quite precious to you the the
keeping what you've built up yeah yeah
so it cuz at first you know people will
expect you to just be super I don't care
about any of this and there's there's
guys out there who are with pawn star
who are just like yeah do what you want
oh yeah I don't think like what our
relationship is is any in any way the
right for everyone I think it just works
for us like for me I did everything I
had all the sexual experiences so I
don't even feel a need but I can also
understand why couples that haven't
experienced it would like to explore
that together the body count thing are
you are you guys aware of your own body
count oh
God stopped counting at like 500 I so
and mostly it's women i f so many women
yeah I I saw that that's like the big
Trend now body count it's it's
interesting yeah because you know and
when your Sicilian body count has a
whole different like yeah exactly he
like which body count are we talking
about here so but it's it's I I mean I
always laugh it's like guys worry about
girls body counts but guys can literally
be like a horny dog on a street
somewhere come on give me a break you
know it's got to go both ways I mean it
really has to go both ways you can't
look at a woman and go oh my God you've
been with 20 people you're you're a
horrible [__] meanwhile you've been with
60 like are you kidding me I think
logically that makes perfect sense but
for the the vast majority of people for
whatever reason you can correct this if
you think I'm wrong I just think men
care more about feeling like oh this
woman is you know mine and hasn't been
around that like men are very
territorial or you know misogynistic
will go with that word too I can
understand that mentality but my I men
have said that to me in the past but my
counter is always wouldn't you want a
woman to be with you and know that your
dick the way you [__] the positions that
you both like the way you know wouldn't
you want her to experience other dick
because if you're the only dick she's
ever [__] and she wakes up someday and
goes you know I really want to put a
12-in dick inside me just to see what
it's like then she cheats yeah so for me
and like for me personally it's like I
would rather my partner go out and
experience everything and then I would
know and feel secure in our relationship
cuz I'm like you did it all you saw the
menu you tried every platter I'm glad
that you chose me you know so yeah I I
always and there's a part of me that
always wonders too and I I did in my
book I wrote about
guys realize that the only place that
they're vulnerable is sex women can make
them do anything with sex a guy will go
places with a with a heart on he
wouldn't go with a loaded 45 I mean I
mean I blow Vic to do Tik toks with me
so it works out like you know right so I
think that men at heart look so Happ
exactly I think men at heart just want
to control that in some way because they
know that's where they're most
vulnerable I mean there really is if a
woman wants a man to to do something
they know they have one Avenue that they
and they don't even have to have sex
with him they just have to flirt with
him half the times and they'll do stupid
[__] so and I think that's why they you
know they ratchet down on it I think
that's why even governments and men in
power ratchet down on sex because
they're afraid of it you make really
good points and I I definitely think
there's a lot of Truth in that I think
the the the fear from some men is like
oh if she is promiscuous then can I
trust her to not be cuz cuz cuz as we
know we can't switch it off and Men know
what dogs we can be so like well if you
can't switch it off then we're really
[__] you know and there is a little
bit of fear there and one of the things
about porn that's really interesting
right now is this taboo going on of
letting people [__] your wife oh yeah
the 22 uh thing I don't know if you're
familiar with there was the Lena Paul
Lena the plug sorry plug thing yeah yeah
he set that up where you know they'd
been doing girls together and she'd been
off limit and then out of Norway they
dropped this trailer of her in the big
black guy and I've never seen the
internet care that much about Pon I
noticed I I don't know the whole story
but I did see some of it on like Twitter
and stuff and I was like I was actually
really
surprised like great PR thing yeah I
don't know what his response I don't
know what his response was or if it was
staged or if it was real or what but I
was actually really surprised that she
got so much [__] for it he got this [__]
for he got L he got oh my God he got cuz
the guy is a big [__] um like what was
it's really hard to explain just I feel
like you just landed on this planet it's
mad yeah no because Adam is a podcaster
as well so he's kind of Dipping into two
different uh worlds in pown and
podcasting even hip-hop and so his
background is podcasting and then he got
with his partner and she's in porn and
yeah so they started making porn
together and it was kind of seen as like
weird for a podcast that to do this but
fair play to you like you're getting all
these women yeah and then out of Norway
so he he kind of I imagine had some pats
on the back and then when he decides to
let her do her thing a lot of the
hip-hop guys the podcast guys you Fu I
can totally see it you went from being
on the top of the hill and getting all
this [__] to being now like oh well
your girl's going out and getting other
dick so he like like I feel like in
their eyes maybe he like fell off the
top of the mountain type situation is
that like with and I think he handled it
as best as anyone can by leaving into it
and getting and making more jokes than
anyone else did so like he's tweeting
out like if you really love your wife
you should let a [__] other guy that's
what I was that's exactly what I was
thinking I was like I actually would
much rather hang out with that guy than
anybody else cuz at least he's letting
her do whatever she
wants I personally didn't find it a big
deal because it's not like look if one
of my mates privately was like yeah
she's got a fell coming around this
weekend like I'd be like what but it's
Adam 22 like it's what he does he's in
the porn game but he quite geniusly
played on the taboo of cook holding and
all of this sort of stuff and then
whipped up the [__] on and I think even
the wedding photos went out like a month
before so he's like oh I'm going to drop
these wedding pH yeah and it looked like
a beautiful wedding the most perfect
wedding and then you've got her bending
over a month later so I do feel like
maybe this was a bit of a gen I mean
we're talking about right now right um
and he made a shitload of money but
that's why I wanted to ask you guys like
whether you'd consider doing something
similar because it just broke the
internet you know and and everyone knows
you guys as this couple now I've never
been one
to I don't know I and like I don't know
if this is true because I don't know
enough about the story but I don't know
if this is like a play to make a bunch
of money and for me I've never made my
decisions in porn based upon how much
money I would make I've always done what
I enjoyed so even the idea of selling I
hate to say this cuz I don't know if
this is true but selling my soul to do
that scene if it is for the press or is
for the money it just wouldn't be worth
it to me but if she was doing it in the
sense of I really just want to explore
other options of human beings even
though we're married I just want to like
I want to know what other experiences
are like I feel like that I'd be all
four but depending on I would never be
like well you know if I do this scene I
can like pretend it's something else and
then make a bunch of money I just I
don't know for me it was like I've got
into it to get laid but you were pretty
you could have gotten laid out of here
no but it was a safe
I I was so shy when I got into porn and
I did it because I I had no game and I
wanted to explore my sexuality safely
the idea of you being shy I know I'm
actually very shy in real life she's
actually very shy I've just watched an
interview last night doing my research
she was like yeah I've had a fist in a
my fist in a man's ass a fist in a
woman's ass oh yeah I I put my fist in a
guy's ass and I clapped in there like a
seal but I'm very shy but she is very
shy and it's not it's I can't even I
can't I can't even like [__] she is
actually pain I'm the extrovert she's
painfully shy if she has to do
appearances and stuff it's like yeah
bragging yeah oh really even even coming
here and she knows you and likes you and
stuff like that even that she was like
just a little nervous like than than
norm and it's and it's funny I'm like
yeah whatever don't worry about it yeah
you really are Care Free yeah I really
don't give a [__] bro I crossed the 50
line and and all my [__] went away if
they were just gone you know yeah I feel
like I'm hitting that early cuz you know
that you see these sort of wise or old I
do who they saw coming out with stuff
and you're like oh you're at that age
now where you're just like this is me
deal with it I really feel like I'm
hitting that commendable I like that I
like the no [__] given the true no
[__] given I really I really think
that's like the ultimate like
Enlightenment is when you just don't
it's funny because there were I mean
there are definitely things I care about
I just have learned not to care about
what other people think I just don't
care I just you know I guarantee you
there'll be a million comments
underneath here making all kinds of
stupid statements I just really I
probably won't even read them and if I
do read them I'm just going to laugh and
say okay congratulations you you had
your five sentences in there good for
you I mean like uh you know if you were
a person in my life who I I was like
let's say you were like my my old man
for example my old man turned around me
one day and he was like yeah I'm dating
a p star now i' be like hey yeah [__] it
you know cuz and I do think that it
really helps you that you're a wiser guy
than
cuz I if you had met Danny let's say you
were in your 30s and that version of you
had met Danny how would you have handled
it because it's one thing being your age
when you've had all these years to
realize well I I mean she would have
been a little too young at no let's just
say yeah there was the insecurity was a
bit higher Fu then I don't know um I've
never like I said I've never been a
jealous person ever like over anything
so I don't know I think
uh the only difference would have been
is at that point I was way more about my
career and about hustling and about
moving things so I tended to and it was
the reason for my split up with my ex is
I tended to put my work first and my
relationship second and I learned later
on that that's not the way it should be
but other than that I don't think I
would have had a I still wouldn't have
had a problem with where we you know
what this was and I just don't I just
never cared you know I I never cared
about my girl girl's body counts my
wife's body count and I just didn't care
you mentioned in your book um had a read
of that last night May about halfway
through fantastic by the way thank you
um dick pics happen to find their way
into Danny's um inbox a lot um I know
you said you don't care about it bit
weird though is it um it's bizarre I I
don't understand why guys do it I don't
it's like first of all most of the time
they send them I mean I have a dick and
I've looked at these things and went
what the [__] is
that cuz I'm the one that show I'm like
look at this one look at this one is
that like an anill in Texas what is that
thing you know and it's like I and I
don't you know I think somewhere in the
book I wrote I said the world would be a
better place if guys realize instead of
sending a dick pick they should just
send a text message that says oh you're
so pretty today how's your day going and
women sent a picture of them getting a
coffee going into a Starbucks the world
would be a better place cuz guys are
visual and women are emotional and
that's just fact the other way the other
way happens all the times women will
send 500 texts and the guy will want to
write stop texting me then delete and
something else and then the girl you
know the guy will send a dickpick and
the girl will be like oh dude come on
man I wouldn't send the dip dickpick to
my wife unless she asked like three
times because even then I wouldn't be
sure she really wanted it so I don't get
it and you have guys like Jeff beos sent
dickpics I mean is your bank account not
your dickpic I mean you need
to the zes are more than the inches
right exactly it's like you needed your
your Jeff P you needed to send a
dickpick I mean I don't get it wild that
just shows that even the smartest man
out here is as dumb as a [__] no I had a
I had a a distant relative wrote a book
called the basic laws of human stupidity
and literally the first rule was
stupidity knows no status there are
stupid doctors and there are stupid
businessmen and there are just stupid
NOS no status and yeah when a guy has
his it the Robin Williams joke the man
God gave men two head and only enough
blood to run one at a time oh yeah you
got a hard on in your hand you're not
thinking thinking straight I don't care
how beautiful your [__] is it doesn't
mean you can use it oh yeah I can have a
really good set of kitchen knives and I
wouldn't be able to cook [__] have you
experienced that before like where yes
you've been with a guy you're like this
should be great and then you're like
okay you well I'm just going to sit on
your face cuz this is a working for me
yes yes just cuz you have a pretty [__]
doesn't mean
anything wow wow you've always got away
with words dad I remember the last time
we had you on some of the one line I was
like this is going in the history books
podcasting it was something like um you
called only fans Uber for my [__] yeah
and then sounds sounds like something
I'd say absolutely yeah I mean I I
personally love that gu send me dick
pics especially my only fans because I
love giving dick ratings oh that's a
real huge thing man oh my God especially
it's femdom like let me [__] roast
your [__] like that's the best day ever
so what what is that how do they react
when you do that I'm really mean okay
give me a pict roast her right now but
they but they ask for it it's not she's
not mean to it they they're like oh
humiliate my she's like oh I'm going in
on this since I've seen you I've been
shooting a lot more femdom stuff okay um
just because I've been like enjoying it
and yeah my femdom content is my
favorite wow and these guys are like
craving the the nastiest can you tell me
just for example like if you don't mind
dipping into the archives of your mind
what is the sort of things that you you
may say to these guys about their
pises for free is that is that hard okay
why don't you send me a photo when you
get fully
hard oh is oh is that how you would
stroke it are you just like overeager
you can settle down you can slow it down
you don't have to be such a [__]
loser if oh do you last more than 30
seconds in bed are you going to last
this even minute now oh you're going to
come already aren't you you're [__]
pathetic for
[Laughter]
free that that'll be that'll be $300
okay that being said it's only with
consent I care about consent so yeah but
all dick ratings uh femom stuff no just
want probably like 25% 30% but what
about the ones who think that they're
bigger and want to hear that and then
you're like actually it's a five out of
10 really yeah
I like um I have some friends that we
talk about like okay but what's the real
rating you gave him an eight but what's
the real rating oh really but all the
ratings are accurate No they really are
my favorite is femdom and small penis
humiliation guys will send me their tiny
micro [__] and they want me to roast
them and it is the best days ever it's
so much fun bro God bless them this we
keep getting you guys God bless them
like these like little T yeah oh it's
the best how small are we talking about
give me an example yeah like like guys
you need to like like guys will jerk off
a two fingers right fully hard and to
come because they couldn't get it yeah
it's awful my fa and then I usually like
he's having coffee and I'm like look at
this guy's tiny [__] and he's like oh my
God go
inside that's breakfast yeah that's like
jump scare just woke up babe could you
give me a yeah give me a break and were
you aware that men with this smaller
penis existed before you got into this
sort of thing or was this your first
experience with a lot of little penes I
me anytime you date a guy you're like
please don't have a terrible [__] just
please just please let it just look like
somewhat decent it's like this I'm sure
it's the same for men I'll tell you too
and it's like these guys they'll send
they'll send their dicks in for rating
and there's a there's a part to it that
you're like I kind of get it they're
probably they're just looking for some
validation in life and it it it's funny
because most of the time they actually
want to hear what I would do with
more like when I get do a rating it's
not like oh I might be like oh your [__]
is so thick or oh you look like you're
like a solid like seven eight in like
not you know but it's more like I would
like to ride it like this I would like
to see how far I can put it down my
throat I would like to like see how
quickly I can get you off just for sport
you know just like stuff like that they
care more about like the dirty talk
aspect I feel like at least for my fans
I can't speak on everyone but um I think
they enjoy more of like what I would do
with that [__] more than like me being
like yeah that would look really good
with like a little top hat and a
mustache
like I've heard I've heard porn stars
talk about like having sex with the
biggest sticks can you describe a bit of
like having to deal with those extra
large guys and how tricky that can be or
whatever if you don't mind yeah no no no
I know I know where this is going did I
tell you about the last stick I ever
took when I was on last time no okay
he's
pry so do you know who Danny D is I've
heard of him yeah okay so Danny D is
this like sweet as PE nice guy English
guy so small like I could take him in a
fight like he's not a big dude no man
he's
118 be a Jo yeah this really sums up the
lord giveth and the lord taketh away
absolutely he got a lot in one area and
the rest this guy has this massive dick
and browers was like I'm going to get
like my thanks browers the scen going to
shoot yeah um but they were like will
you work with Danny D and I was like I
love him he's a really nice guy but he
has a huge dick and I am like I am not
the kind of person that's like what's
the biggest thing you can put inside me
you know so you know how many inches he
is like oh
guesstimate he he's around too he's
like's he's like a Subway sandwich wow
okay he's a yeah he's aot next time you
you're GNA be like God damn it she did
what yeah um I remember like going to
set I flew to Vegas to work with him I
was thinking about getting out like
stopping working with performers I like
you know I just kind of feel like I'm
I've done everything I wanted to do and
I've worked with everyone I wanted to
work with and like I just kind of feel
like I'm ready for this new chapter and
I working with Danny I was like dude you
have a huge dick like I'm looking at
this thing and I'm like and he was
really sweet he's like I'll do whatever
you want I'll lay however you want I was
like okay well I'm going to need like a
solid 20 minutes before the scene starts
to like work my [__] up to like get it
in and he was super cool all right no
problem can you tell me what that means
you have to like do like pregnancy
breathing cuz you can't just start the
scene and be like I think a lot of
people think that like we just are just
like open Gates like yes just give me
all the [__] I'm I thought these women
must be doing something no we warm up
before I mean everyone's different I
warm if it's a big dick I like to warm
up before I like to get my [__] wet
like I like to like stretching before
the marath yeah exactly so I'm like
inching it in and like sitting on his
[__] and like okay okay I can do this I
can do this how painful is that to start
with it actually wasn't painful because
I slowly warmed up to it and so the
scene started we did a great scene he
was very sweet he was very like gentle
and I will never forget it as long as I
live I'm walking through the airport cuz
I was flying back home to LA from Vegas
and my [__] [__] was giving me like
a standing ovation I was walking through
the airport and my [__] was going like
this cuz he had [__] blown it out for
the last two hours and I was like I'm
done that's it I climb the Mount Everest
of [__] and I'm [__] done with it
and um my [__] still doesn't do that by
the way just so you know but uh yeah I
was just kind of like I did where do you
go from here a freight train like what
else am I going to put in there yeah
like there can't be that many guys as
big or bigger than him right yeah and
like I said like I I know a lot of girls
that love that it's just not for me so I
was like you know I did it it's on the
internet here you go like enjoy and yeah
so that's not your ideal is there an
ideal obviously Vic uh pres yeah I just
like a nice [__] that like stretches me
to a nice Point makes me come and I love
a man that eats [__] that would beol
easy to please very simple you must have
a degree in that at this point yeah did
you give them instructions though like
as in like you know when you're getting
to know each other were you very
communicative of what you wanted from
him or was it yeah we actually talked
about it yeah we did I literally I was
like dude I hope you eat [__] and ass
cuz if you don't we're going to have a
problem right out of the gate I was like
I got an oral fixation so we're good we
got this we got yeah fun funny story was
is we started dating long distance so we
spent all this time talking to each
other so we had like two or three weeks
and it wound up being this weird thing
where I met her family and she met my
family and like that it was like 1948
like we met the families and we still
had had sex so the first it was just
like these like freak circumstances it
was just first circumstances so we're
like it's building it's building
building so like the first night we have
sex I'm like you know I'm a 50-year-old
man and she's an adult film star we were
like 16 old kids on freaking first date
we were like trying to figure out how to
get and it was and while I mean it was
amazing it was it was wonderful but it
was hysterical cuz we're like how are we
like so nervous how we had been friends
for a year and a half you had met I I
had met your family you had met my
family we had been like talking and
texting and like discussing like what we
like in bed and then you like get into
the room together alone you're like oh
God I hope this
works there is a lot of pressure a lot
of when you realize like you know like I
think we both realize this might be it
this might be the one and it's like the
first time man you don't want to you
don't want to make a bad repression so
like especially when you're the dude
obviously there's a little more pressure
on this generally you know how did you
cope you all right big
yeah years next fly colors I but it was
it was and we we always joke about it
cuz we laugh cuz we really were nervous
we were like really kind of like giddy
nervous going into it and it's like how
could this be possible and our first
time I was like o do I give him the porn
star experience or do I give him the
Kira experience and what is the
difference between the two when you're
shooting porn it's it's I'm still
[__] and enjoying it but you're
you're playing it up for the camera you
know it's like you or it's like when
you're when you're intimate you know I'm
not like oh my God [__] me like you just
don't do that really like out of the
gate maybe in the maybe right before an
orgasm like right out of the gate not so
much so I think a woman who can perform
a little bit in bed like if they've got
that confidence and I don't mean like
all the way to pawn level but just turn
the volume person in real life but I
don't it's it's authentic women with
confidence are [__] Fant the hardest
thing on the planet when a woman is like
knows you they're confident with you
that's when you're like okay we're good
you know like cuz as men when you feel
like you've got to make all the moves
and do all of the like and do you feel
like it's confidence or do you feel like
vocal cuz I feel like a lot of women
just won't communicate what they want
and I feel like a lot of people like oh
you're a Confident Woman Like no I just
told you that I want you to bend me over
[__] me like that's just like me
communicating I guess for me some women
don't have the confidence to communicate
true and it's it's difficult like it
doesn't feel great when I I you're like
guessing right yeah she it's not even
that it's like she could be beautiful
she could be everything you want but if
you're not telling me you're in this
moment with me then I'm just like I get
what you're saying there's a disconnect
there's it just doesn't work it just
doesn't work put it down to shyness
sometimes like they just don't feel
like they can be that that girl and
don't get me wrong I've definitely
brought it out with you got to say that
I do shower them with praise that's all
we that's all we want we just want to be
told we're pretty that we [__] great
exactly tell a girl she has a pretty
[__] and she'll do anything cuz girls I
I've never been a woman that was not
insecure about her [__] if you if a
girl opens her legs and go damn you have
a really pretty [__] that's it I
guarantee she'll suck your [__]
guaranteed free free Price free free
advice it's great advice well because
some men don't think to say things like
that like and it's not even that they're
not thinking it they just don't want to
say it cuz it's like what if I'm a
creepy weirdo and again that's that's
the that's the big problem right women
want to be told things they are
emotional and men are visual men are
looking at it in their eyes but it's
like say say use your words bro use your
words say something oh my God you know
and guys don't we just don't if if like
not to get too graphic on your show but
like even if like
even if like if you're getting head and
she's doing something that you enjoy
[__] tell her because for us it's
like oh I love when you play with my
balls great cuz I'm guessing down here
so true I'm pulling and prodding and
stroking and hoping that you like it but
if you say like I love that or I love
the way your [__] feels or I love the
way you feel in this position or I like
when you do this like for us we I'm sure
guys appreciate it too it's like I'm
doing a good job it does help that's the
biggest advantage I've got in life as
being a talker and I've definitely used
that in every Avenue of my life you know
what I mean it does help for sure I was
wondering if you either of you this is
worry about your appearance generally
speaking um do you think either of you
is more concerned with how you come
across in public or are you talking
about like appearance like looks or yeah
yeah that sort and I guess there's quite
a bit of pressure on you because that's
kind of your part of your job and I know
you do a lot of photo shoots so that it
kind of must be and you had a little
yeah um I I'm obviously I just turned 34
and I got into porn when I was 21 so
obviously like when you when you're over
30 you start to age and I'm not a big
botox filler person I don't know what
the future holds but in this moment in
time I'm not so I also it's like I look
in the mirror and I I've watched myself
age in
4k for [__] I
know as I check I'm like [__] H yeah
and like and I was trying to explain
this actually to A girlfriend of mine
the other day I'm like women take
pictures of themselves and put on the
internet and it's like just your face
really okay I'm gon to wear a little
like waist snatcher or whatever so I
like my I'm bent over a table and you
can see like my rolls and I'm like God
okay well that's on the [__] internet
forever so it I I do struggle a little
bit like I wouldn't say unhealthily but
I'm not unhealthy like I'm like damn I
got to start working out more you know
the thing that I was sort of thinking
about is when I met well when I first
was introduced to your content you had
the I don't know how to put this but in
the UK we'd probably say the girl next
door look like familiar little bit Out
Of Reach but possible yeah kind of we
feel like we've known her before like
you know and it was it was a a niche
that you owned very much so and
obviously you were so young and to be
expected and as much as you've
maintained your looks very well it's
hard for a woman I think to be dealing
with that level of scrutiny all the time
and it's it's it's really tough and I've
noticed even my content change changing
I went from like girl next door to now
like naughty housewife and like like I
was saying like doing more femdom stuff
like I'm more like womanly I still have
a big ass and so but it is it's like
okay like I'm like more body conscious
like just from age like you as a woman
if you're naked all the time on the
Internet it's it's hard to see some some
days I'm like yeah I shouldn't have
eaten that pasta last night that doesn't
look so
good meanwhile like guys don't even care
they're just like just show us your ass
bend over and jiggle it if you known for
a big ass we want you to eat more I know
yeah I'm like I'm cooking pasta every
weekend I noticed my fans like it more
when I'm thick and like me like being
like a woman over 30 I'm like that's
always that's always my comedy with her
she's like there was stuff on the end
table I'm like if they're looking at the
end I know you're doing the content
wrong hun just in case you're like like
she's like oh my God and I'm like
there's a pillow in the scene I what are
you talking about I was like my
stockings ripped he goes no one's
looking at that no one no it reminds me
of like nearly every relationship I've
been in the woman puts on a stone within
a month of being with me cuz I'm like
what's that oh that's the weight thing
right yeah yeah stone is like we'll use
anything sorry
like4 I'm always like yeah have some
more cuz I like women's thick you know I
me too obviously yeah yeah I've
definitely thickened up I would say from
when but when I was 21 I was like very
small you know it's funny you say that
because I'm I'm conscious of how I
appear for her not because I give a [__]
but I want to I literally want to be
like especially cuz I'm the porn star's
husband so not only looks but attitude
you have to kind of like develop a
certain Persona when guys come up and
it's like you know I I almost it's like
you have to kind of be disarming a
little bit you know they're fans you
know they pay the bills they're fans you
look kind of scary like Vic kind of
looks scary he's a little intimidating I
feel I swear to God Vic has like a
little bit of a mob boss type Look to
Him get that a lot when he opens his
mouth you're like oh my God this nicest
guy ever like it doesn't a little bit
like me apparently say you're totally
different to how you look if I saw you
on the street I would like cross the
street I'd be like that guy's going to
kill me I was I was telling one of your
guys we talked to I Brian is great I
said he's the guy you want in a B I go
that's my friend yeah I said meanwhile
he's like the nicest guy I've ever met
in my life yeah yeah there was a viral
clip of me jumping into a fight uh and
my mate was about to get attacked and
I'm like just straight in the middle of
these guys like all right what the [__]
is going on so you're actually bang on
about
there's been quite a few porn stars
who've came out in the last few years
who are Mega names like uh I wrote down
Mia Khalifa Lana rhods uh Adriana Chek
they've all been saying like how bad it
was and how they regret it I get so
[__] pissed off well Kieran Kieran
kind of was like they weren't saying
that when they were on set paid why
Kieran and I are friends I'm not so sure
about C cuz I've seen her and I I
haven't seen her really trash the
industry but the other two are
nightmares so there's there's a tweet
from her um CU she kind of put this out
saying what if I told you that I hated
that I did porn what if I told you that
I hated my body is not my own I'm tired
of being a product I'm not my own person
that's really killing me I don't want to
tell my truths because you'll use them
against me and then it sounds like she
was just on her period
maybe say yeah or or you know honestly
or she might have had impostor syndrome
where you know and we we've had this
conversation before and and I know my
wife has Illustrated that maybe you
shouldn't get in until you're 2122 yeah
that there's that point time and a lot
of times they get in and you frontal
lobe isn't fully developed you you maybe
you make decisions you might not have
made later on and you regret the
decisions but don't turn around and say
it was the industry's fault I get really
pissed off when I see those stories
because well well Mia and Lana were Mega
stories like they they did quite a lot
of damage with those because they are
the most famous you set the industry
back 10 years 20 years because you made
bad choices and people talked you into
things and now you're bitter about it
it's like I had such a great experience
in porn I loved it I still love it I had
I loved everyone I shot with I never
felt trapped I never felt tricked into
anything but I had the balls to say it I
had the balls to say no I don't want to
do that no I don't want to work with
that person no I don't but people like
okay well maybe I'll do this and okay
well maybe I'll do that and oh I'll do
you know I'll do it for the money or
I'll take the check and get a new lou
bag and then they turn around 10 years
later and they're like I hate my life I
Hate My Life Choices I hate what I did
on the internet well maybe if you had
[__] checked in with yourself every
two seconds and made sure it's something
you actually wanted to do you wouldn't
have been in this [__] situation so
don't turn around and then blame the
porn industry for something because you
made bad choices in life accountability
is a big I get pissed he like everything
is somebody else their mother's faults
their father's fault that because the
job's fault that's who's working for no
it's all your fault it's also it's also
like they're all victims of circumstance
everybody's a victim porn is such an
easy jab it's the same thing like oh
well she's just a [__] [__] it's just
an easy oh well porn was so bad to me
it's like no it wasn't
it's not the modest thing about it it's
great I love it I can't say enough nice
things in the industry you see Lana
rhods or Mia Khalifa using their real
names oh they they're still riding off
the name aren't they exactly and that's
the how horrible was it then or and it's
also like okay do you just need another
press story yeah are you just sit
talking [__] so that you get press
meanwhile all of us that are still in
the industry and loving it and working
hard and have nothing but success
stories and happy memories now everyone
looks at us looks down at us because you
made bad choice or you want to be in
some news article you feed into the
crazy extremists who want to like put a
put a taboo on it like it's 1970 and
somebody just got off the bus from ovar
and they loaded them up with drugs and
they sent them out to do porn and this
is not you know these those are long ago
days this is a corporate it's business
and my wife has said repeatedly when you
do porn it's it's it's a life sentence
period there's no if she cured cancer
tomorrow it would be porn star cures
cancer xor s cures cancer the problem is
is some people don't want that anymore
so they they want to switch it off and
they want to figure out how to get out
of it and the only way to figure out how
to get out of it is go they victimized
me I didn't want to do this it wasn't
really me I only did it for 6 months
even though you were out there for four
years it's like come on I can't I can't
speak about Lana and Mia because I don't
know them but I can't tell you how many
people that I know that don't even read
contracts that don't pay read the script
before they get to set that don't do the
homework on the male Talent or the
female talent and then they wonder why
they get in the situation it's like you
agree to things without even doing any
research and then it's like oh well I'm
mad because you know I did a scene and I
was wearing braces it's like say no no
one is forcing you nobody has you chain
to a wall you are making every decision
in porn you you have the ability at any
moment in time to say no and you choose
not to and it feels like specifically
with those two girls they have made some
of the most money in hisory from porn
from porn like let's not without porn
you guys would be [__] nobody's right
you wouldn't be doing anything and it it
helped you have a beautiful life but I
feel like it's a case of wanting your
cake and eat it like absolutely you you
want to be in a situation where you have
millions and millions of pounds I mean I
know these women are like so rich from
porn are they um well la I was from what
I understood I how do you know have you
seen her bacon cow a there's a lot of
[__] well I might be wrong but I
knew um I knew a guy who dated her and
he was driving around a Lamborghini with
her that she just bought a Lamborghini
he was like this girl's got a lot of
money so let's just say for the case of
for the sake of AR for what she's trying
to put across you got a beautiful life
out of it well you everything comes with
consequences so you you can't make that
decision to do this to get all of that
and then complain about what comes with
it when you let's not let's not act like
people who get into por and aren't away
it's not like a big surprise like oh my
God people judge me like yeah that's why
I pay so well I I literally think one of
the two of them actually said when I got
into porn I didn't realize I was going
to have to have sex oh God I literally I
I swear to you I read that and I'm and
I'm looking at the I was like are
seriously yeah it's hard because I try
not to if you look at my social media I
really try not to get into any like
political debates industry debate I
really try to stay out of it but in
those situations it's hard to watch that
especially when you're when I'm so proud
of doing porn like being part of the
porn industry so to hear someone just
bash it based upon bad decisions you're
just like are you kidding me are you
like you're going to you you're going to
switch sides but yeah you still go by
your stage name you're still having only
fans you're still taking checks you're
still getting checks from pornh Hope
yeah so is it really that bad or you
just bitter about it did you did you
wipe did you did you call PornHub and
say take all my content down cuz they
would if you told them not to take it
down did you you still on only fans are
you still using the name are you still
profiting off the name come on yeah come
on it's a shame it's a shame because
that horrible change your name and it
doesn't matter who anytime these stories
come out and girls you know use them for
attention it's just it's it's sad it's
really sad and you know am I saying the
industry is perfect no of course there's
a small amount of things that could
happen or you know small circumstances
I'm not going to sit here and say it's
all like rainbows and [__]
butterflies everywhere but you have to
have a good strong head about it you
have to be smart you have to do the
research you have to make sure that what
choices you make in life set you up for
your future don't just agree to
everything make bad choices and then
look for somebody else to blame that's
when I get pissed having done PR for a
long time I've done PR for just about
every form of entertainment you could
possibly imagine literally from priests
to to to
politicians in every form of
entertainment there's a CD side every
single one okay and you know it's like
they always talk about oh my God
suicides important yeah how we want to
run through the list of musicians who
have committed suicide and you know even
wrestlers
W and and a lot of times it's
consequences of choices you you made a
choice you made a consequential choice
you went out there you did something and
then you want to regret it and blame it
and the worst part about it is is what
you're doing isn't just trying to defend
yourself you're screwing a lot of other
people you're you're literally screwing
you're hurting a lot of people you're
hurting their ability to earn a living
you're hurting their employees you're
hurting a lot of people even like you
know like the mainstream people that go
on only fans and like scam fans that
hurts us the people that don't scam fans
when you say scum how do you mean I
can't think of the girl's name it's but
she wasn't in porn she was um I think
she was just like a main main former
Disney star not matlyn Ward who's who's
a sweetheart but she went out and she
charged like $1,000 and you know a
couple years ago yeah she got a whole
the only fans had to change the policies
because of it she got a whole bunch of
money and then didn't deliver anything
that she promised meanwhile now people
are afraid to use only fans because
they're afraid that we're going to scam
them you know so it's like consequences
also affect the people around you so I
think one of the hardest things that
I've become aware of after interviewing
uh people like yourselves and Kieran
Kieran said something really deep which
was like people treat him like he is a
danger to children MH yeah like and that
really was kind of hard to CU you know
Kieran like he's he's nice guy yeah
actually gives me chills because he's
like the nicest guy he told me this sad
story about how obviously he's a big
football fan yeah he got this kid who I
I want to say was in a really bad Health
situation he got this kid football
tickets oh and he he got great tickets
cuz he's friends with the club yada yada
Y and um the I think the family who of
the kid were like we don't want people
knowing it was you who got our sick
little boy football tickets because of
what you're associated with you did the
right thing yeah I'm not saying
yeah it's do you have you experienced
anything where you're like I'm being
treated as if I'm a really bad yeah yeah
personally I don't even I don't even
asso I don't have any kids I don't want
kids um I will ply say I've actually had
you know friends that have had kids that
I have had to say I can't go to this
event or I can't because I don't feel
like it would be appropriate because
someone's going to see who I am and
assume oh the oh the porn star is here
there's a porn star over there that's
not appropriate it's like meanwhile I'm
in like this sitting there just like not
by minding my own business I'm like you
only know I'm a porn star cuz you watch
my scenes but that's another
conversation um how do you know yeah I
get a lot of I get a lot of like just
blind judgment for it um and it's you
know it's you just have to take it like
if you're going to judge me without
knowing me that I'm not going to change
your mind no matter what I say so I
would just hope that you would get to
know me as a person before you just like
judge me for my career choices and I
feel fortunate cuz I have a job that I
love like how many people get to do
something that they genuinely love and
are you know financially successful from
it so that's the thing that surprised me
about you is it wasn't really about the
money and the way it was about the [__]
no but but like you say this and like
when I first heard it I was like yeah
sure but the more I've gotten to knowy
you and The more I've seen I've done so
much research on you after two
interviews and watching you two guys
together I'm like yeah she doesn't
really have to do this anymore like I
don't think you actually need to do it
anymore I just enjoy it I just I'm still
enjoying it you got businesses going
left Center and that that's always been
my that's that's always my problem with
the people come out it's like there are
ways to do it obviously we are living
example there are ways to do it where
you can take your name start businesses
phase out of the industry do the right
thing and not screw everybody yeah
figuratively not literally figuratively
screw everybody who literally worked
with you and helped you out and maybe
helped your career helped you build your
name and then you go out the door and
punch him in the head on your way out
the door I don't care how much you Trash
Talk the industry it's not going to go
away yeah and no one's going to accept
you you've ever been to Pompei they I
mean there like on the wall but not even
that like I think people you know maybe
some people think that if they leave the
industry and they trash it it'll get
erased from their yeah from their
history it's not going away if anything
everyone can be a pawn star now
literally it's a bit like being a
celebrity that's that's the other
problem I feel like especially with only
fans is I feel like a lot of people
assume that if I make an only fans I'm
going to make millions of dollars and it
doesn't work like that yeah it doesn't
and like that's the other thing is like
I I I want to communicate like okay
you're making a life choice you might
not make millions of dollars so is it
worth it to you to deal with all this
[__] and all this like you know
blind judgment and all you know have
yourself on the internet forever is it
going to be worth it for you if you only
make a couple
thousand the fun part going to be
something you enjoy or CU if you're
doing it for the money it's not the
right choice yeah you really the bizarre
part too is everybody thinks that I'm
attractive male or female going to drop
my clothing do 20 minutes to work and
make a billion dollars if they took two
days to watch what my wife has to do
every day not just you know the 20
minutes of shooting she's got alarms on
her phone when she has to post she
engages with fans she's got to upload
you got to edit content you have then we
have all the other businesses that we do
all of that stuff it's we work
constantly to maintain this not working
looking lifestyle and and these guys
don't grasp that you're not just going
to drop your clothes and make money you
better bust your yes you better work
hard everything requires hard work
everything requires hard work and no one
has patience anymore we live in an
instant gratification and that's she
always laughs she goes you're the most
patient person I know it's like when we
wanted to create the underwear that we
we sent to you guys took us two years to
do that very good underway by the way
yeah thank you but it took us two years
to do that and my wife went nuts making
sure that the band was perfect and it
fit I love
the what it say remove to [__] yeah but
it's like quality stuff high quality
and she wanted it to be that way most
people 3 weeks in would have dumped it
the the the content game whatever kind
of content you're creating it's a lot
harder than people understand for sure
it's whatever goes on off camera aot is
the hard bit and I remember I spoke to a
cam girl once who explain to me like I
am up at night for hours and hours
talking to these guys when they're
coming in from a nightclub night and I'm
trying to keep going and grinding and
she was like I am exhausted I sleep the
day away I get up have aof and I'm back
on the internet all night and that
really hit me I was like [__] that
sounds hard and you're talking to guys
who were drunk like you know they're
asking and she said like they'd ask her
for like this freaked me out actually
cuz she was like they one of them asked
her for like inappropriate pictures of
her when she was younger those are the
ones there's a little bit of like not a
little there's a lot of mental with it
too because you have to deal with that
I've had I've gotten like people show up
to my house death threats stalkers weird
questions like you're ring yourself way
too quickly would they people show up
the yeah we had we had we had a stalker
outside our house in Manhattan for
almost 3 weeks and it was a woman it was
actually a woman we we've had the whole
what kind of woman was this and why was
she there uh we think communicate no we
we we had to call the cops and we had to
get them most of this stuff stems from
like a lot of those romance scams and
Ghana scam stuff oh can we can we
explain that because I know we touched
on it last time but for those who don't
know you have so many many millions of
followers who and there's a lot of them
who want to contact you and there's
people who are praying on them
pretending to be you to get money out of
them is that correct correct and is
there any more information that it's
actually gotten worse because um
Instagram now because of the
verification what people are doing is
getting a an account verified with
whatever their ID is and their whatever
the face is and then they switch it to
my name and my face but they stay
verified right and then they go in as a
verified account and they're pretending
to talk to my fans like oh this is my
super secret personal account um you
know I'm make [__] [__] [__]
story whether it's like I'm leaving Vic
or I want to be with you or I'll fly out
and [__] you or you just send me all
this money and then this all your
magical dreams will come true I I
guarantee you at some point in one of
your comments it's going to say that's
an old interview they're not really
together anymore Oscar wild said it's
easier to fool somebody than convince
them they've been fooled and that is the
the most accurate quote I've ever heard
in my entire life because once people
start paying into this there's a there's
a feeling inside like it can't be fake
because then I've been screwed and I
have to believe and they keep sinking
more money into it I just had someone me
said they thought they were with me for
the last six years six years never met
her face to face six years you've got
problems have no no but like I mean you
want to be
scammed there's no sympathy yeah like
we've had six Christmases I've not seen
you yet yeah right exactly I've not seen
you at all I me six birthdays six I mean
you know wild but even if it's how much
money are we talking about millions
millions i' I found out about that lost
$150,000 and you said in total it's like
millions millions and millions and
millions ofar a year and millions a year
and that's just her that's not including
like Elsa genene who's also and there's
many other people in the industry it
it's they can find you know obviously
nude photos of the these girls online so
you can create an intimate relationship
most of the people that they're going
after are not I look very Girl Next Door
very girl next door like you were saying
earlier so it's I have an unlimited
amount of nude content photos videos um
that you can use to pretend to have a
relationship Jesus when you put it like
that especially now that I'm shooting at
home and I'm on my couch and I'm in my
bed and I'm not you know cuz if the guy
goes send me a picture of you drinking
coffee we can find that yeah easy but
but send me some nudes even better yeah
and and if I get one I get 20 emails a
week going you know you're not really
with her uh You' stolen all her money
you better get it back where I'm going
to call the police and I'm usually
writing back going please please call
the police please please get them
involved please but I mean it's weird
thing it's gotten crazy we we had a
policemen show up at our door this this
true story I'm out back like doing
something and the person knocks on the
door and they're like hi I have the
Miami Police Department on the phone we
need to talk to you about your daughter
and so so I freaked out so she that they
met my daughter my real daughter yeah
and she was like oh my god daughter went
to Miami she got a car accident
something orble the guy wanted to know
about her three-year-old daughter well
we don't have any kids your
three-year-old daughter is in danger
this is a police officer police officer
like you're detective detect you know
help us out here bro I don't have any
kids oh well we got this this call I'm
like you didn't think to like do your
little laptop for 5 seconds and figure
out that I don't have any kids why would
somebody do that well are you sitting
cuz we're going to tell you the story
and you could see the poor police
officer in our town is like going oh I'm
so sorry like he's looking at us like
it's but that's I mean we've dealt with
this over and over and and she said
repeatedly she goes of all of the things
that I expected in porn this was not it
this was the this is by far the most
difficult thing in porn that I was not
prepared for and our biggest issue is we
can't get any help now we've we've
contacted and talked to like the FBI and
stuff they're almost powerless because
it's overseas they can't really do
anything but we can't get the social
media platforms to take the fake
accounts down yet they'll they'll knock
her account down every six months well
because of the content yeah but you've
seen her content my page it's it's it's
well s yeah I do pretty I do a pretty
like however the fake pages will put up
the wildest [__] they'll find the old
scenes and put it up and we can't get
them to take the accounts down even
though she's a verified account we can't
get them to take the accounts down we're
like all there's no privacy aspect when
you join a social media platform it
would literally take them two seconds
they can probably write an AI script
that looks into the DMS and seems them
asking for money from people and just
wipe the account that's all you have to
do just wipe the account out nope not a
damn not help at all and it screws a lot
of people there are a lot of people
losing a lot of money and then we have
to wor feel bad I feel bad like I get it
it's a it's funny it's like oh they're
an idiots they should evolve for it but
there are people that just spend couple
bucks here couple hundred bucks there
maybe they think they're getting you
know a scene of mine maybe they think
they're I don't know paying for me to go
out and suck their dick whatever
[__] lie they sold but it's like
it's I feel bad it's like you fall for
these scams and I'm trying to help but I
like I've seen you post repeatedly about
this and youve tried to put the word out
at a s just yeah yeah and and you know
it's and I know a lot of times she gets
really upset because they are using her
image to take money from people who
can't afford to lose the money and it
and it's stings a bit and you know you
got to get a you get a little thick
skinned about it because well like we
have tried I can't even tell you like
every podcast we start off she'll she'll
State the date and go I'm still married
to Vic and we still can't get don't fall
for scammers it's literally in the bio
of my Instagram it says don't fall for
scammers pretending to be me and I still
get it and then they'll at some point
I'm like I put up my hands and I'm like
I don't know what else to do this is is
my full-time job like wow it could be a
full-time job and we talked to years ago
talked to a guy from the FBI and he said
oh he goes if you think you you've got
10,000 he goes we have 10,000 a day he
goes it's constant and it's all usually
coming out of West Africa and they have
boiler rooms of people there and up on a
bulletin board somewhere it says
everybody today is Elsa jeene and they
all go out there and they have like a
bunch of different things and it's all
the same stories my dad died I'm stuck
in Ghana I'm going to nursing school my
husband beat me it's all the same
[__] you would T sister that's a big
one twin sister that was my favorite
twin sister don't a twin sister for the
record doesn't have any siblings
important to say I don't feel like I
should have to say that but now I feel
like I do I mean this isn't an admirable
thing they're doing but on on the one
hand I'm kind of like [__] hell these
guys are
grinding and they're the best profile
they're better profilers than the FBI
they know exactly which guys to I follow
like if I make a friend and I follow
them on my porn account on my porn
Instagram they will instantly get like
30 fake Danny Daniels accounts that
follows them that tries to like them up
yeah no no I'm not just saying this by
I've
had 20 to 50 of of your versions of you
and I've had DMS I'm like this is
[__] so weird and and the thing is
is you're not even really the t i I said
to them I'm not actually true Jord I'm
his twin brother that's what you should
do from now if you send me
$5,000 you can me the real and it's it's
it's ins it's insane that you have to
get to that point you're not really the
target a lot of times what they'll do is
they'll find you know a guy who's a
little bit older obviously looks like
he's lonely or something and they'll
look at their bio and God forbid he
commented cuz we've got them send it to
us they'll be like I saw you commented
on my page and I thought you were really
cute and now my comments are going to go
down on Instagram thanks VI this is my
this is my super secret page and we can
chat here just don't tell my husband
it's like I think I'd be really good at
picking those guys
up I know it's not a nice quality but I
can spot a loser
my and so can they and so can they and a
lot of times these guys I mean I feel
bad of times these guys are lonely and
I've gotten messages and I'd probably
say about 70 or 80% realize they got
screwed and they're actually nice about
20% can get really up IM your mess oh
God your messaging the husband of the
woman you think is going to fly over the
sea and you're like so you're still with
her then literally literally hey by the
way I just want to know um are you and
Danny still together yes um well I've
been getting this you're not talking to
her but she sent me these photos I'm
like dude they're everywhere yeah it's
like you
you can get them for a lot less than 5
grand if you sign up to my only
fans yeah exactly and and the bizarre
part too is it's like I almost want to
type back and go you knew you knew deep
down you knew cuz you wouldn't have
messaged me if you didn't realize that
there was something going on but and
it's sad because some of these guys like
I feel bad for them I really do they
actually come back later on you find out
I don't know they lost their wife or
something happened and like they were
just lonely guys who got prayed upon by
you know scammers and I mean it's just
like like they pray upon Elderly with
banks scams the same [__] going
about the humiliation stuff you
mentioned earlier I've heard about
people who like this the financial
domination those are my other
favorit yeah keep those are my other
favorite yeah we love the financial
domination love it I love a man's wallet
anytime but at least those guys know
what they're getting into right I think
I was unaware that I was actually in one
of those relationships for quite a while
I just didn't know
it but what the [__] like what kind of
messages will those guys send you like
what and what are they what are they
wanting cuz I don't obviously I've got
no idea why a man would want that but oh
I love it it's like um they want to buy
me things they want me to make a wish
list and they want to buy me what's on
the wish list and they want me to have
control of their wallet and decide you
know how much play money they get you
know if their paycheck is I don't know
off the top of my head two $2,000 okay
well I'm going to spend you know ,800 of
it and figure out how to use the next
you know two weeks on 200 bucks that's
so so
scary but but this again this is consent
this isn't me like taking a fan and
trying to like screw him over this is a
fan coming to me and being like I want
you to control my wallet I want you to
dominate me financially I'm like say oh
I love a dirty
man is there a worry cuz the reason this
worries me is to me if someone said to
me if some anyone came up like let's
just say a woman on she was on the other
I want you
financially that will be that'll be the
[__] day I'll never that will never
be women will
never but let's just say it happened I'd
be like this [__] is crazy I
I some people will like take credit card
info or like debit card info I won't
because I just I'm like it's just too
much of a a line for me so I have a wish
list and I just go go to my wish list
and buy me those shoes um take me
shopping like I'll have like a little
like oh like you know spend this much
money and I go shopping with it or buy
me that I want that for a scene or you
know get me that new kitchen a mixer so
I'll like make them they have to do it
and that's just like my own personal
like Comfort um but I know I know plenty
of dominatrixes that'll be like yeah
give me your credit card info good luck
that would scare me that I that they I
don't know if these women are thinking
along the lines that I am in terms of
like consciously about the circumstances
that where you're then putting that M
but how do you but I'm or the ciran
you're putting yourself in when they
decide to report it as credit card for
it I'm not face to face with this person
and I don't know what his real
circumstances he might be playing a
character just like I am he might be
like I have $500 to spend and I just
want you know I want to pretend it's my
last $500 and I want her to like you
know just you know degrade me and use me
and not give me any attention so I don't
know and that's also why I like to use
the wish list aspect because I feel like
for them they are now in control it's
their choice then much like only fans
you you know you're paying for that
excitement or whatever whereas if you
give a woman a credit card deals and she
just [__] yeah like what if I just
like swiped it for first of all I feel
like that's some sort of illegal
something somewhere down the line and
then like if I just like go and swipe
his card for five grand it's like I
don't know what his actual I don't want
to actually hurt this guy I just want
him to like enjoy it and get off on it
and pay me for it like do you think this
just I I'm wondering at what point do
they get off on it like do they like say
the statement and be like oh God so I
think everyone's a little bit different
yeah that's so much money how am I going
to eat this week
but they're like enough over that like
but some guys too will like they like
seeing me in what they bought so like
they they enjoy like buying me the
lingerie because I wear it in a scene
and they and then they jerk off to it
that makes sense too so it depends
there's different there's different
there's makes sense I would do that but
yeah it I I kind of it makes more sense
than just looking at their screen and
watching their bank balance kept
annihilated know mean I have a lot of
guys that like can I please give you my
credit card info and I have have to tell
them no just from for personal Comfort
but I that's a smart thing yeah yeah I
don't know just it's like I don't know
there's no safe word with like my shoe
addictions so yeah you know if if if uh
let's say uh a woman who you happen to
know came to you let's say she's just
working a normal job I'm sure there
might be a woman watching this right now
who might be considering this what sort
of um reasons to do it and reasons to
not do it would only find um would you
think about only fans like you know do
do it if you want to do it for this
reason if it's for this do not do it
like is there anything you well first I
would say like what do you want to do on
only fans because you can you don't have
to take your clothes off at all you can
just do domination you can just like
what we were saying you could just do
femdom um you could you know ever some
of them don't take their clothes up yeah
depend no it depends on that like some
performers they do like foot fetish you
know latex maybe they just only do latex
maybe they do um just jerk off
instruction r play dirty talk so not
everyone needs to get nude but it's like
if you go that rout okay well why are
you doing porn if this if you're going
to go the porn route are you doing it
because you enjoy it are you doing it
because you want to explore it okay what
is your current job is that going to
affect it is how are you going to feel
when your all of your family and your
friends find out because they will
absolutely how are you going to feel if
you know it comes up in conversation
because it will how are you going to
feel like if you get judged blindly
because you will and it's like I would
it if those things didn't exist but they
will because that's the reality of the
situation of the world we live in Riley
Reed came out and spoke about how she'd
just been basically disowned by most of
her family happens a lot it was brutal I
was watching it like it happens a lot
unfortunately it's like it's it's it's
sad it's there's a bizarre thing too
where the family all of a sudden has a
problem until they start making a lot of
money and then they're fine with getting
the money from she kind of said I don't
know if you heard that bit she said her
mother was on the take like oh I'm cool
if you're giving me some yeah it's like
wow yeah that's really it's sad but that
happens a lot and friends and everyone
finds out about it you know when I first
started doing and now it's a little bit
different because only fans but they'll
still find it everyone's like oh well
you know you have to sign up no
someone's going to find it someone's
going to think it's hilarious and send
it to all of your friends that's such a
good thing to point out though it
because it is like that is the norm
right like that you be you become a pub
story you know something to laugh about
oh when I started doing like mainstream
porn and the people I went to high SCH
with found out about it my phone
literally went like dink dink dink dink
dink dink D CU you could just sell it
just like threw the grap Vine like if I
found out someone I knew was doing pora
I would tell everybody about it because
it was me it would just like oh my god
did you hear about so and so like
sucking dick good for her like you know
so one of the main main things that's
happening in America especially right
now is people in regular jobs are
getting exposed so we're talking nurses
teachers and even someone who was
running for office got exposed was being
on chat bit with her fell and she's
trying to be a politician she was good
looking politician as politicians
politicians [__] you every day so you
might as well be on only fans like J it
would be amazing if we lived in a world
where you could do only fans and and
these sites and still have you know your
job of you know but it we don't live in
that world and I feel like people have
this fantasy in their head that oh I
hate my job let's just say I don't know
you work at a coffee shop I hate my job
at a coffee shop I'm going to do only
fans on this side I'm going to make a
bunch of money and I'm going to quit my
job and be able to do only first of all
porn's not forever so I hope you're
saving the money and not just like
blowing it on Lou bags second of all if
it doesn't work out you're going to have
to go back to that job if they'll even
have you like when you find out about
like teachers doing only fans I'm like
you're working with kids and you're
surprised you got fired from your job
like this isn't the you know we don't
live in this like like fantasy land that
you think and you're not going to make
as much money that you think you're
going to make unless you grind and
hustle and work you know full this isn't
like a suck a dick for an hour and go
home and have wine you know and do you
think that there's a direct correlation
between the amount of money you make and
the things you're willing to do yeah
maybe yeah well I think a lot of the
time for people definit the porn stars
that I have become familiar with are the
ones who you know if you have a thing oh
are you saying like the aspect of like
oh I'll do butt stuff for like 5 mil is
it like that is price tag on it the the
women who seem to be higher up in these
porn categories seem to be getting gang
bang by 10 dude like there's no limit
with them girls I haven't done a gang
bang and I'm top 25 I mean that is true
but is that a
rareity yes yes and no though because
you have like like bry's on there and
she's never done butd stuff okay so
there's two no there's if you go for if
you go through that if you go through
that top 25 you'll see it's more likely
that there's one of every category
there's a skinny girl there's a blonde
girl there's an you know an
African-American girl there's an Asian
girl there's you know a girl next door
there's more likely to be that and some
of them have limits they they haven't
gone over the edge and then there are
many people who go over the edge and
can't crack inh some of it has to do
with a little bit of an X Factor like or
do you involve your fans in more than
just your porn because if you don't
you're going to go up and the moment
that they're bored with your porn you're
going to go right back down I think it's
also I did mainstream porn for 6 years I
was on browsers and Pen I was a
Penthouse Pet and I did all of these
different mainstream like sites I didn't
just like start an only fans and in
Instagram with no following and start
making millions of dollars a year so I
think that's the the Dynam like I the
people always say like oh my God how did
you get so popular I'm like I've been in
this industry for 1 13 years grinding
for 13 years you're not just you don't
just like you take your panties off and
like get instant Fame it doesn't work
like that yeah I think it's sold as that
and and then when you talk about the X
Factor there's also like and I don't
know if this is just me but I think
other dudes are like this as well like
sometimes the prettiest porn stars
you're a bit like me but then there's
ones with clear personality who are
putting everything into it and they make
you feel like almost you're in the room
sort of thing you know and I think those
girls definitely seem to to do really
well I want to ask you a little bit at
the end now about the age capap between
you cuz I think that is quite an
interesting thing to deal with and um
what is the Agee Gap
okay so you guys seem like clearly twps
in a pod and I think anyone who's
watched to this point will just get that
it's you know you're double act um but
but do you think about the long term and
you know like one day you will be on
your own after this and how have you
made peace with that and how do you feel
about that the pair of you uh we stick
our head in the sand and pretend doesn't
exist yeah a little bit a little bit a
little bit in reality yeah we do we do
have had some conversations about it and
and the running joke is is she's going
to be stuck with my kids when she gets
older but um yeah I mean we're the we're
we're literally the same distance that
Lauren ball and Humphrey bogar war and
you know obviously he died young but
that was like one of the greatest
Hollywood love stories of all time and
it helps that I'm Juvenile and she's not
so we get we get much closer yeah much
closer in age Gap when she's an older
soul and I'm basically a child in an
adult's body so I guess it's one of
those things where it's like would you
just tell some not be with someone
because you're the fear of being alone
what if I die first yeah that's not
happening God I hope I die first I don't
want to deal with that that be I'd be so
sad like yeah the the reason I brought
it up is when I was thinking about it's
it's one of those awkward things to deal
with in life and a lot of couples do I
mean like older guys with younger women
is the most normal thing but I just
wondered where if you given it much
thought and if there was like you know
if this happens here's what we're going
to do or have you talked like that or
yeah we' we've talked about like Estate
Planning and wills and that kind of
thing and I mean I think you have to do
that when you're with somebody for long
enough you have to kind of figure out
like Hey listen you know you never know
what's going to
happen like something happens you know
you never know but I I didn't even think
about the age Gap until people started
bringing it up all the time and then
like even now I don't even think about
it until these conversations come up I'm
like oh yeah like at some point you know
but I would never trade it for anything
oh I'm not suggest not at all CLE that
you wouldn't yeah but it's no it's just
like it's just like surreal you're like
yeah you know someday like I just wonder
I just hope I go first let's say that
you don't go first which obviously
statistically more like do you think you
would you know you you've had your
marriage in your life and you'd be like
that was my great love of my life right
but would you do you think you'd go on
and meet other people and just sort of I
don't think or do you think You' just be
like nah that's it for me no I don't
think so yeah I don't I mean I don't
even said I'm going out when you die I'm
just going to go and be like gang bangs
every day just line them up know I'm
just kidding I'm just kid you know how
some some husbands are like
I either don't want you to go and be
with other people and have company or I
I do or whatever yeah I wouldn't care
like if I di go out go get some [__]
like live your best life yeah I think
I'm in the same boat as you I don't
think I would I mean I don't know it's
like you don't know what Life deals yeah
it's I had a relative years ago once
told me Death is certain life is not so
go out and live go out and live and I
took that to heart a long long time ago
and I started realizing man if you go
through life trying to figure out when
you're going to drop dead or when the
next shoe is going to drop you're going
to drop de the next Sho is going to drop
that's just what's going to happen but
if you go through life trying to live it
at least then you have something when
it's all over and done with you know you
can look back and go that was a life
worth living uh not a life that I wish I
had done 5,000 other things and I
learned really early on in life through
through a decision that the the things
you regret most in life are the things
you don't do you know the things you do
do is like at least I gave it a shot and
and this is like you know I'm I'm older
and I'm hoping I last for a very long
time but at least I've had this period
of my life and it's the happiest time of
my life so
wow I sucked his dick for
that and and that that was so beautiful
and you
ruined all right that that genuinely was
such a nice thing to hear and it was
probably one of the nicest things we've
had said on this podcast well done
brother thank you he definitely getting
laid there's a poet in there um what a
beautiful performance from you too thank
you very much um smashed it that was
once again Danny Daniels and her husband
Vic chipa chipa there we go on the true
Jordie podcast appreciate everyone who
watched you can check these guys out
follow them they're everywhere millions
of followers and we'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
cheers